nós vamos bater um papo hoje sobre o
poder das mídias sociais e o mais legal
que o que eu trouxe para vocês é para
falar não só das mídias sociais no lado
profissional quando a gente fala das
empresas executando algum serviço a
gente vai falar principalmente de vida
carrera e o mais legal é que eu vou
poder compartilhar com vocês como é que
as mídias sociais me ajudaram a realizar
um sonho de entrar na área de educação é
bem bacana porque assim quando eu falo
de mídia social eu começo a me lembrar
de uma frase que eu li e falava assim ó
a internet é uma rede de pessoas não de
computadores eu li um livro chamado
google market isso foi mais ou menos em
junho de 2011 e eu lembro que essa frase
me marcou porque a gente fala assim ó
quem trabalha com mídia social domina
todas as tecnologias entende de
informática entende de ferramentas só
que na verdade trabalha com mídia social
e além disso eu tenho que entender de
gente eu lembro que essa frase me marcou
no livro mas por que que eu tinha lido
esse livro em junho de 2011 o que que
está
e me preocupando estudar mídias sociais
naquela época se eu nem trabalhava ainda
com mídia social na verdade eu vou
voltar um pouquinho com vocês nessa
imagem aqui essa imagem na verdade foi
postada por uma empresa aérea aqui no
brasil em abril de 2011 quando eles
completaram oito milhões de passageiros
transportados então o que que eles
fizeram postaram isso nas redes sociais
e falaram olha só estamos comemorando
até que os nossos funcionários que nós
completamos 8 milhões de passageiros
transportados por esse brasil e
agradecemos a vocês entre os sempre fui
muito apaixonado por aviação então sigo
todas as empresas aéreas nas redes
sociais e vice post nessa época eu não
trabalhava com rede social eu trabalhava
numa área de uma empresa lá em são paulo
sobre pesquisa e compra de imagem para
revista eu tinha rede social só para
ficar fotógrafo internacional últimos 80
amigos no máximo e tudo mais que
aconteceu eu vi esse post eu fui lá e
fiz um comentário 8 milhões acho que
hora
a fazer uma promoção relâmpago de
passagens por outros reais serão sucesso
com certeza e quando eu vi 9 likes eu
nunca tinha recebido novilax naquela
época a gente foi a eu vou aproveitar
isso aqui eu acho que eu tiver comida aí
é muito revolucionária já sei cheguei em
casa e cria uma campanha numa campanha
passagens aéreas a r$8 criar um evento
no facebook e convidei meus 80 amigos
vamos agitar e coloquei a questão
coloquei assim ó fomos nós que voamos
somos nosso primeiro temos também
comemorar esses oito milhões que
aconteceu quando eu fui ver tinha um 29
mil pessoas convidadas o negócio
espalhou e o que aconteceu agora começou
a mandar texto olha só mais um dia
passando a galera esperando estamos
querendo saber né cristiano santos m
marcavam pessoas que eu nunca conheci
mas eles continuavam fazer a questão ó
bom dia galera vamos continuar essa
campanha não acabou bom fim de semana a
todos né cristiano santos gente sem
brincadeira eu ia todos os dias mexer
nas
dá para ver como é que tá a sua campanha
e eu respondi a comentário por
comentário mas porque eu voltava da
faculdade chegava uma hora da manhã em
casa e falava assim eu nem vi essa
história eu preciso agora falar com
essas pessoas eu senti uma obrigação e
quem já me conhece assim sabe eu tenho
um costume muito grande em redes sociais
que eu posso até demorar um pouquinho
mas eu costumo responder uma um porque
eu sim que tinha lá em 2011 uma ideia eu
acho que esse é o nosso diferencial essa
atenção que principalmente em redes
sociais as pessoas têm essa necessidade
de carência de as pessoas falarem com
elas e adivinha todo mundo começando a
postar marcar o chris 1 hora da manhã
respondendo chegou um dia que eu acordei
assim tava indo trabalhar e mandar uma
mensagem cris você viu lá no mural do
evento eu falei o que há com a companhia
aérea aceitou fazer uma promoção de 8
reais e o que que eles fizeram eles
avisaram oi pessoal iremos fazer essa
promoção iremos saber queremos saber
quais são os trechos que vocês gostariam
de
e o que aconteceu por um mais de 50 mil
comentários no post deles das pessoas
falando com as trechos gostariam de voar
a gente costuma falar isso aí redes
sociais do famoso caution a chamada
atração olha diferencial da empresa ila
e falar olha pode para a gente faz só
uns trechos eles usaram isso como
pesquisa claro e ao mesmo tempo
estratégia de engajamento e adivinha
quando eles fizeram isso eles começaram
a fazer outros pulsos também falando
assim bom dia vamos lá tá chegando o dia
da passagem aérea r$8 a empresa pegou
carona nisso isso tem nome a gente chama
de persona e persona em rede social não
é só a persona do cliente que compra mas
da empresa e a linguagem que ela aplica
então a gente tá falando de 2011 ea
gente já tá falando das empresas
aplicando personas para poder conversar
com seus clientes e aí a gente começou a
ver empresa ingá jando em piragi indo
conversando e adivinha chegou o dia era
mais ou menos assim umas 9:50 da manhã
era 28 de maio
olá tudo certinho essa data eu tava com
um amigo meu a gente tava no carro assim
eu falei assim cara eu preciso utilizar
esse computador agora porque vai começar
uma promoção de passagens aéreas por 8
reais eles falaram que vão vender
durante uma hora apenas chegou a hora 10
horas da manhã eles começaram a vender
vários trechos eu comprei vários trechos
que eu nem sabia que que eu queria fazer
aquela cidade mas eu falei é muito reais
da gente era oito ida e oito voltas e o
que aconteceu quando essa campanha
aconteceu e as pessoas começaram a
comprar uma amiga minha que trabalhava
comigo nessa área de pesquisa de foto me
ligou e falou assim oh cris a campanha
deu certo eu falei assim pelo ela cara
posso contar para uma amiga minha de uma
revista sobre a sua história é uma
revista de negócios né posso contar para
ela sua história eu falei assim claro e
que aconteceu eles me ligarem falar
assim crises queremos uma entrevista com
você para colocar na nossa revista sobre
como é que se mobilizou esse monte de
gente fez uma empresa através das redes
sociais vender passagem e aí eu fui lá
entrevista tudo mais né
a pergunta de uma das perguntas dela foi
cristiano você pretende fazer novas
campanhas e gente não dá gostinho da
fama para quem nunca fez o porquê é bom
na hora eu falei assim ó eu vou fazer
novas campanhas eu vou sim nós vamos
movimentar-se brasil e que aconteceu ela
colocou na matéria cristiano irá fazer
novas campanhas siga ele no facebook e
aí começou aquele monte de gente me
adicionar e falando assim cristiano
preciso de passagem para salvador me
ajuda eu mas isso na campanha tem que
ser uma coisa natural a campanha em rede
social porque senão fica falso né não aí
que aconteceu como isso daí começou a
virar um sucesso na mídia todo mundo
lendo espalhando daqui a pouco eu recebi
uma ligação um canal de tv falando assim
olha cristiano temos uma matéria aqui
numa revista que você não especialista
em mobilizar pessoas e redes sociais eu
fui na brincadeira isso aí não mas tudo
bem nós estamos fazendo um documentário
e queremos que você tem um depoimento em
nosso documentário e lavar eu viajar
para gravar uma entrevista na tv um
documentário sobre mobilizações em redes
sociais
e os casos de pessoas que estavam
criando qualquer tipo de evento nas
redes para utilizar pessoas legal tudo
isso aconteceu matéria foi no ar as
pessoas começaram a mandar mensagem na
minha rede social planta assim cristiano
cadê a campanha nova que você falou na
revista que você ia fazer gente eu fui
falei assim quer saber eu tinha feito
uma campanha de oito reais eu tinha
feito uma campanha de oito reais para
uma companhia aérea eu falei não agora
eu vou fazer uma de 10reais para mudar
um pouquinho né eu falei assim ó eu vou
por agora para todas as companhias
aéreas que eu quero todas não quero mais
uma só não e coloquei fiz essa
brincadeira e o que aconteceu um milhão
de pessoas convidadas isso daqui começou
engajar e as pessoas começaram a clicar
no evento e quiseram participar e
algumas empresas aéreas já começar a
responder iremos fazer essa promoção
vamos engajar e tudo mais legal só que
daí que aconteceu o rh da empresa que eu
trabalhava me chamou falou assim o chris
eu posso pedir um favor para você nós
vamos ter um evento digital aqui para os
nossos jornalistas você poder dar uma
palestra sobre a história da azul para
eles aí eu falei assim mas eu nunca
palestrei na minha vida tudo bem não
tudo bem eu queria que você contasse
essa história da forma que ela aconteceu
coloca os prints e conta para as pessoas
como foi o passo a passo e o que
aconteceu gente eu fui fazer essa
palestra só que eles avisaram olha
sentido de jornalismo né cris você sabe
os jornalistas vão querer um além não é
só a história como você não trabalha com
rede social eles vão querer que você
fale por que que você acha que essa
campanha funcionou por que que você acha
que deu certo não foi só uma questão de
apenas fazer um post brincar deve ter
alguma ideia na sua cabeça alguma
intuição e fez você querer levar isso em
frente coloca isso que tá valorizar
palestra coloca no finalzinho eu
coloquei isso no final e o que que eu
coloquei no final eu justamente eu
coloquei um slide falando assim ó qual
foi o diferencial nessa campanha de
passagens aéreas na minha opinião na
época e apresentei isso aqui para eles o
primeiro deles eu falei
e atenção aos usuários e as suas
necessidades e o que eu quis dizer com
isso na época que na verdade quando eu
ficava até uma hora da manhã respondendo
pessoas eu fiz um uma das premissas que
redes sociais na verdade as pessoas
gostam muito que a receber atenção então
entender principalmente o que cada um tá
falando então esse daí já começou depois
eu coloquei um ponto que era
transparência e ética o que eu tô
querendo dizer com isso que a gente
falava assim não você deve ser ligado
essas companhias não você deve está
sendo pago para se infiltrar no meio das
redes sociais e fingir isso e eu falei
assim não gente a campanha é realmente
assim sem nenhum tipo de envolvimento
com ninguém e até por isso eu acredito
que ela funcionou e outro detalhe tá
foco rede social exige muito pouca
porque teve gente falou assim que eles
desculpa r$8 ela não vai aceitar mais
uma de 20 aí falei não não posso mudar o
preço porque você mudar um preço agora a
minha campanha ela perde a validade
porque não tenho originalidade né e
outro detalhe credibilidade porque
eu ia responder num chamando as pessoas
que tava começar a fazer elas iam na
página da companhia aérea e um
comentando os pulsos da companhia a
culpa ele colocava temos promoções a
r$50 hoje não queremos queremos o
direito reais o cristiano santos isso
veio da credibilidade que eles falaram
assim ó o cris tá comprando uma briga
com a gente e outro detalhe linguagem
simples e da onde vem essa linguagem
simples se a gente fala na rede social
com uma linguagem que não é a nossa o
que as pessoas não nos conhecem ela
sempre essa dificuldade os nossos pulsos
tem que passar nossa verdade eles têm
que ser na verdade uma representação
daquela sua fala e um detalhe importante
e aí eu acho que na verdade fez a grande
diferença uma relação direta entre
empresa e clientes foi ali que eu
percebi que uma ação em rede social na
verdade de uma brincadeira fez o
contrário fez um marketing um contrário
porque nós juntamos as pessoas
interessadas e já levamos as 29 mil
pessoas e falamos assim empresa x temos
aqui 29 mil pessoas querendo passar
o que que você pode oferecer para nós e
aí foi ali que eu falei assim caramba a
gente fez um movimento inverso né beleza
terminei essa palestra duas semanas
depois arrasar me chamou e falou assim
cris tinha um dia doutor presente ali na
reunião e ele falou assim o rapaz pode
não ter o conhecimento de mídias sociais
de ferramentas técnicas mas ele tem
conhecimento sobre o lado humano de
interação que nós queremos aqui na nossa
área e essa empresa criou o primeiro
cargo de analista de mídias sociais para
o sumiço em junho de2011 como eu nunca
tinha estudado que que eu fiz é que
aquele livro que eu falei para vocês
aonde eu fui começar a estudar então o
que era mídia social para fazer curso eu
fui participar de tudo quanto é evento
linguagem porque afinal a brincadeira
virou profissão e se ela virou profissão
agora eu preciso levar isso a sério que
aconteceu depois disso na verdade quando
eu falei aquela frase para vocês esse a
internet é uma rede de pessoas e não de
computadores que ali naquele
e aí eu comecei a perceber o tempo que
eu trabalhei em mídia social pensando
nas pessoas em um ano em 2012 eles me
convidaram poxa cris eu cuidava de um
produto ele falou assim eu poderia
começar gerenciar agora as 16 marcas da
nossa empresa nas redes sociais isso um
ano depois de começar a estudar eu falei
assim caramba mais uma brincadeira daqui
a pouco eu comecei cuidar disso e aí que
venha ficar a questão mais importante
que eu considero essa questão da minha
vida com mídias sociais pessoal porque
na hora que eu comecei a ver isso
acontecer eu comecei a trabalhar com
isso mesmo de verdade a valorização das
pessoas foi quem mais fez diferença na
minha vida porque de repente eu comecei
mais para frente a receber convite para
dar uma palestra um curso e tudo mais e
para quem já fez uma palestra um curso
comigo e tal conhece que eu sempre levo
no final uma cortina vermelha free não
eu quero dar aula agora sobre esse
assunto eu vou levar uma cortina eu vou
levar assim o segredo que está ali atrás
e aí é sempre as pessoas ficam assim que
será que eu fiz leva porque eu só revelo
no final da al
a consciência por revelar aqui que no
final atrás da cortina vermelha sempre
está a minha mãe a dona nair e a dona
nair tem que a dona nair ela tem que ser
101 anos de idade ela não tem rede
social porque ela não gosta de rede
social lá fazendo quero whatsapp não
quero nada não tem nem celular só que a
minha mãe gente eu comecei a levar ela
principalmente nas palestras porque ela
tem uma importância nesse processo todo
só que assim eu comecei a mostrar ela as
pessoas começar a mandar recadinho para
dona nair eu liga para ela e ela falou
assim fio agora tu não seguidores é isso
e agora ela fala assim nossa eu tô
famosa nossos maracaju ela falou assim
aí eu posso uma foto do meu seguidores e
olha só como é que a dona ele agora mas
voltando por que que o cris coloca
sempre nos fins das aulas e palestras
dele quando ele começou a trabalhar com
mídia social a imagem da dona nair
porque ela é uma das responsáveis para
realizar um sonho na verdade um sonho
que eu lá atrás eu já tinha de ser
palestrante ou professor aí eu me
lembrei que na verdade com 14 anos de
idade eu tinha
e eu montei uma escolinha numa cidade do
interior de várzea paulista interior de
são paulo onde eu montei duas latas
coloquei uma tábua dois blocos eu tinha
alguns alunos 23 alunos de cinco anos
para ensinar a ler e escrever eu montei
esse escolinha nessa casa em construção
porque eu falei assim cara eu tenho um
sonho de ser professor só que você tinha
tanta vontade de ser professor naquela
época que eu fiz eu queria ir lá dava
aula para essas crianças e de repente eu
fiz uma lista de chamada com o nome de
todas as crianças da rua porque eu
queria fazer chamada igual o professor
da escola eu chamava todos os dias
aquelas crianças elas nunca vieram gente
sempre voltarão e todo dia as crianças
ficavam falto faltou dona nair uma vez
passou e fala assim fio fica calmo hoje
você tem uma escolinha mais um dia você
vai ter uma escolona e o que isso
começou a acontecer galera na verdade
isso começou a crescer e quando comecei
a ver essas convites para palestras e
cursos e começar a falar com pessoas do
mundo todo eu
e puxa a escola na vila verdade e não só
isso isso aqui é uma imagem porque é um
cara que tinha uma escolinha lá no fundo
do quintal lá numa casa em várzea
paulista essa pela imagem da dona nair
foi chamada comigo para ir para um
evento e falou assim dona nair seu filho
ganhou o prêmio do profissional de
social media do ano o professor do ano
ela falou assim eu não falei que a
escolinha virar escolona e não só isso
essa imagem foi que um evento chamou ela
e pagou tudo e falou assim ó cristiano
ela vai subir no palco também nós fomos
para natal juntos e ela foi nesse avião
inteiro tudo pago ela falou assim ó só
famosa agora vou subir no palco também
virou influência e outro detalhe isso
tudo eu tô contando para vocês porque
porque recentemente eu recebi um prêmio
chamado linkedin top voices brasil como
um dos 20 brasileiros que mais gera
engajamento no linkedin eu falei assim
muita gente me pergunta poxa cristo mas
de onde você tem esse prêmio para mim
gente quem me conhece no linkedin ou
qualquer outra rede social é a
humanização quanto mais humanização a
gente traz nas mídias sociais as
a web principalmente porque não só o
linkedin mas qualquer rede social ela é
viva quanto mais a gente põe um pouco da
nossa história as pessoas não querem
conhecer é só o seu lado profissional
elas querem conhecer também sua família
o que que você já passou e não só isso
isso me deu coragem em abril desculpa em
março de 2017 eu pedir demissão da globo
para que fala assim ó não não tem mais
como eu preciso sair na verdade para o
mundo para poder ensinar outras pessoas
porque eu senti que na verdade naquele
momento a educação pode mudar o mundo e
as redes sociais no poder de auxiliar
nesse processo eu falei assim ó adorei
trabalhar com esses 10 anos mas eu quero
sair para o mundo e ajudar as pessoas eu
não saber se tava certo em pedir
demissão mas eu segui um sonho de
verdade falei eu quero levar a educação
para frente isso começa a acontecer esse
ano o meu primeiro convite para nova
york através das redes sociais que me
acharam depois recentemente foi um
convite para o japão e aí onde eu po
os brasileiros que moram no japão sobre
redes sociais daí a gente fala a gente
imagina que uma brincadeira em rede
social pode ter se poder de mudar tudo e
aí foi onde eu não sei o chris na
estrada a ideia de um professor
itinerante que leva conhecimento pelo
mundo a qualquer canto e nessa ideia de
realmente poder espalhar aquilo que
começou lá atrás eu acho muito bacana
porque se conversa com a minha missão é
o que resgatar a autoestima profissional
das pessoas através da educação para
inspirar e transformar a carreira a vida
delas o que começou na brincadeira na
verdade hoje virou uma coisa que eu falo
assim quando a gente aprende algo mais a
nossa autoestima profissional recuperada
por que você fala assim ó eu posso mais
do que eu podia antes então isso é muito
bacana porque eu tô falando isso para
vocês porque quando eu estava no estados
unidos na minha palestra de repente
minha família falou assim você viu cris
se essa rua de várzea paulista para o
mundo pensa uma coisa você saiu para lá
você começou a poder viajar e vou
e lá quando era criança ea família falou
assim parabéns que nós temos uma foto
aqui que eu acho que você vai querer
mostrar na sua palestra que a foto da
escolinha isso aqui foi onde tudo
começou essa foi a sala onde tudo na
verdade era um sonho apenas e através de
redes sociais através de qualquer coisa
foi aqui dentro onde eu comecei a ver
que um sonho de infância foi se tornando
verdade através de um ponto muito
importante que a educação e aí eu
gostaria de perguntar para vocês de
verdade ou é sua escolinha ou é aquele
sonho de infância que muitas vezes a
gente cresce esse corpo de adulto faz a
gente pensa assim ah porque ela esquece
e a gente guarda isso daí para depois
porque você sincero gente não importa se
eu estou falando com uma com 10 ou com 5
mil pessoas toda vez que eu estou aqui
na frente para mim é como se eu
estivesse dentro dessa escolinha
é muito obrigado a
e por favor